hey everyone it's evan i'm fresh off a
new haircut i came back i wanted to
record this video right away this is
extremely raw video i didn't even give
it to my editor to put the usual intro
extra all that stuff on because i wanted
to talk to you today i'm really excited
i just launched my new home page if you
go to evan carmichael.com you'll see
what the new layout looks like and i
need your help if you go to the home
page you'll you'll see a new message if
you turn on your speakers turn off any
sound you have going on you're going to
hear an inspiring minute long message
from one of my favorite entrepreneurs
steve jobs now what i want to do is
build up a collection and here is how i
hope you guys can help me out
what i want to do is create a collection
of short inspirational bursts of
speeches from entrepreneurs we can all
look up to
and respect and learn from and create a
series of these segments that are one
minute long something that you would
listen to every day
the problem is
all of these videos most entrepreneurs
are not doing a great job telling their
story and the inspirational advice is is
broken up
amongst a huge number of videos or
amongst a huge speech there's like one
good two good segments in there what i
need your help is finding those great
segments what i want you to send me is
your favorite entrepreneur videos the
most inspirational advice you've ever
seen or ever heard on youtube from
entrepreneurs ideally you can break it
down you know from this time to this
time on the video and ideally overall
the total time is one minute from all
your favorite segments
i want to launch a tool so that when
people come and visit the home page
every time they come they're getting hit
with a different message a different
inspiring
theme from a famous entrepreneur because
starting the business is hard and
keeping it going is hard and we need at
least i need constant motivation and
constant support to help me keep going
and so i want to build this resource
nobody has done it before
it's a ton of work and i want your help
so for those of you if you're interested
if you guys have liked the stuff we've
created if you've liked my videos if
you've never commented or gotten engaged
anyhow this is your chance i need your
help check out the home page first you
kind of get a sense of what i'm what i'm
all about what what the new plan is all
about
and then check out the videos that you
love online again it has to be a famous
entrepreneur somebody would look up to
so i'm not looking for athletes or or
you know movie stars looking for people
who are entrepreneurs who have their own
business who are making a name for
themselves their most inspiring clips
break it down on each clip what time
segments i should be listening to that
really serve to motivate you something
that you could listen to every day and
get inspired
and ideally it's one minute total per
entrepreneur and for people who do this
i mean hopefully you're doing it because
you believe in the movement you want
something that's going to inspire
yourself and also have an impact this is
going to be seen by millions of
entrepreneurs and so i want you to be a
part of it but as an added bonus
for anybody who doesn't we use their
content we use the videos you just send
in
the links to the videos you're sending
with the time segments i want to do a
one-on-one chat we can do it by phone we
can do it by google plus
and give you advice to help you grow
your business as well hopefully you do
it because you believe in the cause you
believe in the movement you want
something that's going to help you out
and impact millions of people but
there's an added little free bonus in
there as well
so again i didn't want to let i didn't
want to give this uh to my editor i
wanted it out right away i just recorded
this i just pressed recorder popping it
up on youtube
and i really need your help guys so let
me know i i'm excited about this
resource we're going to build we're
going to impact millions of people let's
do it together
and please leave a comment below letting
me know the sections that the the files
you like with the segments or send me an
email whatever works best for you please
help me out i'm so excited about this
project and i really hope that you'll
join me thank you so much i'll see you
soon